IBM's recognition as a leader in ESG
reporting a new European mzr in Spain an
icct's summer of certification all on
this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
the market landscape for ESG reporting
and data management software has evolved
rapidly over the past three years driven
primarily by increased regulations and
interest from a variety of internal and
external stakeholders
it's an incredibly important field and
that's why we're thrilled that
independent research firm burdantics
recently identified IBM as a leader in
their report green quadrant ESG
reporting and data management software
IBM has a strong Heritage in helping
clients around the world use Ai and
advanced analytics to address their
sustainability goals
IBM sustainability Solutions provide
clients with an end-to-end solution to
manage ESG Data Drive performance
improvements and address reporting and
disclosure requirements
the verdantics report notes that IBM has
strengths in data quality control and
enhancement as well as ESG and
sustainability performance which is
exactly what we're striving for
to learn more about IBM's sustainability
Solutions and what they can do for you
check out the blog in the description of
this video
next up IBM recently announced the
opening of its first multi-zone Cloud
region in Spain comprised of three data
centers the mzr is designed to enable
European clients to deploy their mission
Critical workloads with high levels of
resiliency performance security and
compliance
our goal is to help Enterprises
especially those in highly regulated
Industries meet the European Union's
Regulatory and digital sovereignty
requirements
the opening of this mzr represents IBM's
largest investment in Spain and one of
the largest in Europe it will host more
than 600 clients including Acacia bank
and RSI
best of all the Madrid MGR is powered by
100 renewable energy
so it can help clients further Advance
their sustainability objectives
to learn more about the plans or on
IBM's New Spain mzr hit the link below
to close things out today I wanted to
let you all know about the IBM Center
for cloud training's summer of
certification program which is offering
a faster path to IBM Cloud certification
and a discount on all exam fees
this year our summer of certification
provides a unique opportunity for
streamlined certification as an IBM
Cloud professional developer or IBM
Cloud associate SRE
the two courses have been updated and
restructured to get you certified faster
we're also offering special vouchers for
50 off exam costs for any certification
all you need to do is register now for
an online or in-person exam and utilize
the code you'll find in the blog linked
below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now